Jerome
lovely to see you again
[Applause]
the Continental that we meet at the
beginning is probably one of the worst
Continentals in the world it's decrepit
it's corrupt it's messy Cormac who's
running it is amoral and vindictive
shoot Mr Avery for me sir the rules oh
yeah the rules again
all right
gentlemen
we fell in love with this idea where it
was set in the 70s because it felt like
it was a way to expand the world but not
step on what we had in the movies the
big ass from The Producers bazo I wantic
and Erica Lee is we want to know more
about the inner workings of this hotel
what we learn in the Continental is how
Winston and his personality how does he
build this hotel in His image you know
usually when a bunch of guys in Mass
drug me and throw me in the back of the
truck and fly me over the Atlantic
they at least offered me a cup of coffee
yeah of course Sharon being the man
just like in the films the hotels
mirrored Winston Soul rules
without them we live with the animals we
wanted the contents all to mirror
beginnings of Winston and who he was I
don't think fans should miss this for a
second because they are going to see
things that were there that now they
know the history of watching the
character of Winston being brought into
the underbelly of this crime family from
London is really fascinating oh my God
this is the love of my life you
protected with your life or don't come
back
you've got my word
the Continental is such a huge part of
the movies it's our hero location and
something that fans are always asking
more about this kingdom is mine and mine
alone it felt like everyone was
intrigued by John Wick and then
underneath it they're intrigued by the
character of the Continental when we
started thinking about the prequel we
went back to watch the films and we
realized what we're not giving the
audience anything it just almost like
assumed the fact that they would know
why this hotel was here and history
behind it
a lot of the elements of the Continental
are elements that we had in the films
just weren't really addressed
John Wick
ex-communicado
hi
it really comes down to one line when
Winston says I have served and been a
beacon of order and stability to our
industry for over 40 years so I pulled
my calculator out and I was like well
the movies came out in like 2015 2016.
what was happening in New York City 40
years prior clever and landed right on
this article about Fierce City and the
Peril that the city was in the
bankruptcy the violence the Bronx
burning
and so it was one of those aha moments
where we went wait a minute
what if we go back to the beginning what
if we set this in a Time far away from
John Wick but also start to plant the
seeds of how John Wick comes into this
universe crazy thing about the John
White franchise is that it's not based
on any underlying IP it's not based on a
graphic novel series or books or it's a
remake so every piece of information we
give the audience is the first time
they're experiencing it every little
kind of breadcrumb we give them they are
intrigued by I'd like a tasting I need
something robust precise
would you help set the mood for our new
guest of course so
if you're a fan of the John Wick film
series I think you will really
appreciate the things in the Continental
the rules the danger the violence the
fun how are we supposed to believe a guy
in an ass guy can pull this off it's a
cravat
as filmmakers we always wanted to
explore the behind the scenes of the
Continental who cleans the rooms the
hotel who gets the mail there's another
kind of Upstairs Downstairs of the world
that we just started to explore and
could go much deeper in as well counter
to the fact that the John with movies
are going so fast
in some ways the first three films only
take place in like a two-week radius so
we don't have time to slow down
and talk about the mythology and so in
some of these other pieces of content
we're doing we're going to spend more
time trying to dig deeper and answer
some of the questions that the audience
has because we've kind of just threw out
a lot of Mythology and people are
intrigued by it but we have to go deeper
bigger than goons or bookies or broken
fingers they control everything they
have eyes and ears everywhere they make
people disappear
you thought you could outsmart the high
table
how foolish of you Albert and our
showrunners were incredibly respectful
of the franchise tell me what you need
love
can you dig it
you know living up to Fan expectations
so that's a pressuring challenge but
then you have to create a new world what
season we planted in the films that we
can kind of go backwards and exploit
we have new rule about that the red
light goes on you can kill in hotel
grounds
[Music]
been activated let's take this house
foreign
[Music]
the expansion of the hotel itself was
something that was kind of a process
because it's an odd shaped building
right it's a triangle that doesn't look
very big but you have to make it feel
ominous and that's what's interesting
about the Continental when you watch the
movies all that stuff really fits in
that building
are there these really big rooms that's
kind of the mystical quality of the
Continental oh hello is this how you get
to the gift shop
we see the whole schematic the early
designs like where the pivotal points
are how the rooms are laid out we
learned the DNA of the hotel which is
really fun and nothing that we've ever
explored in the movies before is
everything in that building who knows
what else he's got in there now
we never went about it as like okay
let's just do all these different rules
more so let's experience the Continental
through a young Winston we had to have
Winston and Sharon and really build
their relationship because that helps
tell the story of the Continental Hotel
13th floor that's bad luck right
I'm not superstitious
if you do want to leave the audience
wanting more we do want them to be
asking more questions and so I think
it's just more of kind of letting the
Rope out slowly
I think they're gonna love that we took
the world that they know and they're
familiar with and expanded it a bit more
we've just scratched the surface I think
the beauty of a hotel there's so many
rooms and arms and so many interesting
characters that we hope to explore more
of we're going to spend more time trying
to dig deeper and answer some of the
questions that the audience has about
the history of the Continental from the
films the Continental that became the
most powerful one in the world
how did that come to be I'll see you all
at the grand reopening
foreign